[Music]
okay everybody so this is my spoiler
review of severance episode 3 in
perpetuity this was again directed by
ben stiller like the first two episodes
but it's not written by the showrunner
eric dickerson this time it's written by
andrew colville so there's so much to
unpack in this crazy episode they're
throwing a lot at you it demands a
re-watch to catch little things little
hints about what's actually really going
on the first couple things i've caught
is that when petey asks mark about
anyone living nearby he mentions about
this character we know is peggy is the
neighbor right but he mentions that
there really didn't fill up the
neighborhood that much so this can get
theories going because we get a lot of
shots of the neighborhood we get to see
more of it where mark lives and how
literally all the houses look the same
they're all blue everything around them
is blue but it's interesting because
it's definitely set up by lumen right
like that we have this watchful eye
maybe for lumen employees that he
probably wouldn't recognize from
different departments living in that
same neighborhood we're going to get
into peggy in a second because we get a
lot of reveals already and answers about
her character in this episode but i
really love this standout editing
especially in the scenes when mark is
talking to petey and we see petey is now
dipping out of his workipedi and audi pd
in his head i love how it blends both
environments visually so well where
he'll have the outfit on from his audi
while he's in his working environment in
the office or vice versa and it really
is cool because it's explaining things
that he's remembering that actually did
happen in the office and how it's
connecting to present day so petey while
he's talking to mark about everything
he's talking about his reintegration and
these people this group that doesn't
believe in severance and that these
people who reintegrated him aren't the
protesters at mark met it's a different
group and he also brings up to mark how
would you feel if you knew that you were
murdering people eight hours a day which
is a crazy line and he says he found a
department they don't tell us about
where you don't get to leave like
they're down there right now so this is
gonna get you know reddit going crazy
everyone's theory is going crazy like
what is going on in this lumen building
but they justify him not giving mark all
the answers here because of him going in
and out of these visions these episodes
he's having these side effects of the
severing and the reintegration he's just
all messed up here so right away this
episode gives us the answer that peggy
is not severed and that this is the
peggy we see at work and that she is the
neighbor and she's fully aware of it and
she's got a watchful eye on mark and we
learn even more about peggy which is
crazy which we're gonna get to about
another name of hers harmony who i
really think is a real name but there's
some great shots here and creepy stuff
going on where peggy's just watching
mark at night and she's like oh you poor
thing but i love that they show him walk
between two windows again like with the
two fish in the apartment it's showing
these two lives two versions of mark
he's walking through that she is
monitoring literally and metaphorically
and she's chewing one of those cookies
she gave him so get theories about those
cookies going because we're gonna see
irving which i'll point out each time
referring to mark looking like he's had
food poisoning so who knows what's even
really in those cookies peggy is giving
mark and another crazy thing is we see
this new segment mark's watching and
it's the lumen representative and i'm
guessing hr person
natalie who we see later in episode who
is the communication between the board
and peggy and she's offended by the word
worki and enzi and the person who she
offended by saying this i'm guessing is
a man who is from this group that
reintegrated petey and we see the
headline is saying that four states
proposed to anti-severance legislation
so this is again a really big topic in
the world at this point and i love some
writing here in particular when petey
says to mark the next morning at work
you would come in with red eyes you
carry the hurt with you you feel it down
there too you just don't know what it is
this is great and this just sums up also
why adam scott his performance has been
brilliant i said in my previous review
he does such a good job especially in
his work version of showing a man who's
forgotten things but he's dying inside
it's visually on his face there's
something very sad in between all this
despite having the surgery and i love
too with the editing and the directing
by ben stiller decisions he makes
everything's so thought out and really
tight and well done and i love that
right when mark goes on this elevator
are we hearing a lot of dramatic music
to this point the second the elevator
door is shut and he's going to work the
music cuts i love that so back to what i
was saying about the food poisoning
theories right irving's just throwing
these quick lines like you look trim
mark i wonder if you were food poisoned
and later on when irving sees mark after
he talks to hely he says i'm worried
stress you're having is too fast to be
having after having food poisoning so
they're reiterating this line by irving
so it has to mean something and adding
to mystery of the show one of my
favorite mysteries going on is about
heli because we see mark is giving his
first time these morning announcements
and the big one is that helly's
resignation request has been denied and
he's never seen such a quick turnaround
of being denied so she says that can't
be right my audi wouldn't do that but we
don't know a lot about helly's audi and
it's a fascinating mystery like why is
she so hell-bent on having herself go to
this company what is this heli what
happened to her in the real world so a
lot of the humor of the show comes
through the brother-in-law and his books
he's writing and i love that he drops it
off at that mark's house and peggy goes
and grabs it she has to grab it because
she's got to check for any notes there
but it's just funny when she gives it to
milchik later on she's saying it's his
fifth book and he's reading a line about
being emotionally nude to your wife i
thought that is just so funny but what's
fascinating about that little scene
there was how quickly he throws the book
down when mark walks in the room just to
keep face and that mark wouldn't even
notice that at the office but it's gonna
be interesting too to see where this
comes back later on that when mark sees
his sister and his brother-in-law again
they're going to be like what'd you
think of the book and he's like i didn't
get a book so that that has to come back
and you also see little details like
peggy has a key to the house it's a
lumen key so going back to that theory
about how this whole environment is
probably owned by lumen and very cool
again with this editing with pd having
these visions of when he was in the
office and it's coming between him and
the real world but he's drawing a sketch
in the basement here of the building of
lumen but it brilliantly shows us
through the visuals of him when he was
at the office talking to mark that he
was drawing these sketches in the office
that his reintegration was happening in
the office it was already started there
and that's mentioned later on by peggy
as well but it also is a good tease to
the reveal later on that this sketch he
was doing at his desk was in the frame
that mark will find at the end of the
episode i also know your theories i mean
this is totally out there was when peggy
is in mark's basement and just takes a
candle out of his dead wife's crafts box
and she keeps it so what was that about
i could not figure that out for the life
of me what was also interesting was when
petey was walking on this bridge in
present day and he's following these
notes he was scribbling it's showing you
he was also following these notes at one
point in the building itself of lumen
trying to kind of investigate this
building what's going on and probably
when he found out a lot of crazy
information so a lot of commentary like
i mentioned the first review about just
corporate life office life we live in
today is really leaned into in this
episode and the satire of it we'll see a
lot of too and that comes a lot through
dylan's character and it also comes with
just scenes of how mark and helly
interact and the moments like when hell
is in the bathroom trying to find a way
to escape and write notes on her arm
he's bringing it up she should be proud
of like the amazing things she did with
the numbers the day before and it's like
those moments we felt in the office of
wanting to quit and someone that's
always there kind of like reminding you
like how you know you're doing good
though don't leave and it's like
interesting to the commentary and how
they set up these four characters of
irving dylan mark and helly because it's
like like i said helly's the audience's
lens right we're going through her of
like learning everything and then mark
is someone who's kind of showing us the
themes of the show we know the most
about him outside of work and we're
relating to him emotionally but then you
got dylan here who is kind of just that
guy we all know in the office who's
really the voice of reason and truth
here and like pointing out all the
messed up things office culture does
where irving's a complete opposite or
he's the believer of it and he is
admiring this company and wants to work
his way up it's it's really well done
how they kind of plan that out with the
four characters and you even see irving
saying that you know dylan's bringing up
incitives of the company and waffle
parties and he's like that's not what
this is about you know this is deeper
than that this company that's not why we
are here he says and that's where he
gets the idea of his deeper meaning that
heli needs to see and craves let's take
her to the perpetuity wing and like i
was saying how this episode leans into
that commentary on corporate culture and
how messed up it could be they do a
great job about showing it especially
about office communication between
different levels of power and you see
that when mark wants to talk to peggy
just for a moment here you know they
mention again that he has to fill out a
request to speak to a supervisor she's
like no no he can talk to me so again
this is great they showed this little
moment with mark and peggy because peggy
on the other end has to do this too with
the board when she talks to them how
cold it is and she can't even directly
talk to them she has to talk to them
through a representative for them the hr
woman natalie which we're gonna get into
that scene but you see peggy throws this
mug at mark and says what i just did was
something i knew you could handle and
grow from it was very painful for me i
hope that you will let it help you i
mean haven't we all had abusive bosses
like this that maybe not that extreme
maybe that extreme but either way just
behavior that's abusive and they justify
it that way they say they feel bad but
it's to help you you know and patricia
arquette is the best actress to deliver
lines like this so effortlessly and it's
just corporate abuse and brainwash and
you see it's coming down from her also
in a sense being abused by a board and
talking about that scene which was one
of my favorite scenes with this big
reveal that it's natalie from the tv we
saw but the bigger reveal she calls
peggy harmony so she's that's got to be
her real name and that peggy is another
just fake name on top of fake names that
this character has and she thinks the
board's going to want to know what's
going on with helly but no what they
care about is pd because pd's the threat
to something bad happening for this
company and she mentions like i said the
prior departure troubling signs of
reintegration was shown through pd and
natalie's like on the phone with the
board is like board is saying pretty
strongly that the severance procedure is
provenly irreversible which we know is
not true it's maybe that it's not fully
irreversible which is true but i mean
that what we've seen so far what's
happening with pd but there is ways to
adjust it and they say that the manager
of the severed department should know
these things and when she
answers and gives her reasoning and what
her plan is they already hung up on her
which was just so true to real world
life here about how this corporate chain
treats each other and how supervisors
just goes on and on whoever's under them
this is very accurate and that you can't
even have a 101 conversation and you see
the satire really leaning in when
they're seeing the o and d department
optics and design and we see bert again
with this other woman and they're
talking about this training they had
with these eggs egg drop challenge and
you see the different reactions where
dylan's calling bs on it and hates this
guy bert and doesn't trust him but
irving looks up to bert you know this is
what he likes and it's a lot of lines
here you got to pay attention to that
are super important in particular that
stood out to me too is dylan just saying
how like they're the cruelty department
here no other department is that was
fascinating that makes you wonder about
the omd department and that they had
this coup that happened years ago and it
makes it that much more scarier that if
this violent coup is true that irving
admires burt in this department and
going to that observation again of
office commentary and how we are
brainwashed by admiring these great ceos
and great values of a company
and that they were shown that through
them looking through this perpetuity
wing and i'm sure when you're watching
this and looking at this wax figure of
the current ceo you're thinking of
westworld right away i know that's where
my head went this is where the show most
felt like westworld in all the good ways
and if you like this obviously you
should watch at least westworld season
one which is brilliant not gonna talk
about season two and three but watch
that season but it's so similar you know
and having this corrupt company corrupt
ceo but that exciting mystery about what
is the vision totally here how did this
start where did this begin where are we
it's so fascinating and then we see this
room of the former ceos but really the
most significant one being kier egan and
he's audio here talking about taming of
these four tempers it's like these flaws
in the human mind and adjusting it in
the mind and you know people are gonna
observe that bingo card shot we got of
heli holding it and you see things like
you know lumens referred to as she
unexplained eagan death so it's got to
be a side effect of some kind of surgery
they were doing maybe severing and you
can depict it with halo this says
everything here too that you know he's
really looked at as the god of this
company this here e and i mean they
literally made a replica house of where
he lived but what's important is irving
talking about not having a history that
history gives a shape and waking up on
that table i was shapeless because
you're deleting your history right and
you see the quote when you enter here
history lives in us whether we learn it
or not and then we see that irving says
but then i learned i work for a company
that is actively working for mankind
since 1866 so it's almost shaping your
own human history to the company's
history to their view on the world and
what they want you to do for them and
it's kind of like a commentary on the
show it's like these people don't bring
their human touch to it their own story
it's they're put into the story of the
company that they made for them and it
makes us robots in a sense and i love
the humorous line here but it also means
a lot too and they see the replica house
and heli's like jesus and irving just
says no here like again just saying to
you like that's how he's viewed here
it's interesting you can't lay on that
bed in the house and mark our character
mark you know he obeys the rules but
he's always curious you know and he
wants to lay on that bed and that's
obviously where irving calls him out but
heli books it at this moment we got this
intense scene with a lot of handheld
camera work that i thought was really
effective here where a lot of times
would make people nauseous and is
overdone but it really works in the
sequence of mark chasing helly and
that's a serious cut she gets in her arm
trying to escape so they're gonna have
to give her a gift card like they gave
mark and some kind of story of what
happened at work for her audi but we get
more into this creepy break room right
and we knew from petey's tape last week
that they have this brainwashing going
on about everything is your fault right
now we see the big reveal part of that
is that there's a lie detector in the
room with you so you really have to
convince them that you're saying it and
you mean it which was crazy to me and
just sick and twisted but awesome and
props to the actor milchik here he kills
it and i love his line i'm afraid you
don't mean it that was where i just got
chills down my spine you got peggy
watching just great directing by ben
stiller as well some of the shots he got
with peggy's eyes through the line she
has to read everyone here just crushing
it and we're getting all these little
answers with more questions again
they're doing such a good job of that in
a mystery show a good balance and we see
mark's replacing the desk photos of the
group photo of pd's with now along with
heli but he finds on petey's old one
this map and this is where petey's
bugging out in the gas station he's
trying to put tokens in the machine like
they do at lumen and it's a nice touch
when he's in this gas station he's
surrounded by lumen products like lumen
cola and mark will see pd being taken by
this ambulance and this freak out and
like collapsing which is bad one because
he's collapsing and she's got to scare
mark because it's showing you the side
effects of severing and of reintegration
and that no way about it you're not
going to end up good health-wise from it
and also this is bad news for pd because
now his location is going to be found
out by lumen so i'm sure pd is not going
to make out of this alive either way and
it's setting up such an interesting
storyline because we're just waiting for
audi mark to connect with working mark
and connect the dots together because
you're seeing working mark learn more
information you're seeing audi mark
learning for more information but he's
got to transfer it to both marks it's
really just awesome fresh stuff and
fascinating i know i sound like such a
fan boy for this show but again this is
my favorite type of show you know i am
so hooked into this but it's also really
really good whether you objectively like
this type of genre or not it's so well
done it's exciting me and the big
cliffhanger here is that petey left his
phone in the basement in his days and
that mark found it so this number
calling mark i'm gonna guess is this
group that reintegrated pd or maybe it's
someone else maybe it's petey's daughter
who knows maybe it's lumen so we'll see
but this might be you know more of a way
that mark will find out more about
what's going on in lumen whoever's on
that other end of the phone call so real
exciting cliffhanger so well done this
episode i i don't know like i can't say
anything wrong about it it was so
entertaining the mystery is awesome they
just added more stuff giving you already
so many answers especially about peggy
aka harmony and
we're getting more mystery added too i
love it i'm loving all the performances
and ben stiller man like i liked him as
a director but he's blowing me away how
good he is now these first three
episodes so props to him uh i'm excited
the writing's top notch and it seems
like eric dickerson as a showrunner has
a good vision for this so um i'm really
pumped to see where this goes but i'm
giving this one a 9.6 excellent stuff
and it's only getting better and better
for me right now but let me know what
you thought down below give me all your
theories i want to hear them please
subscribe so miss one of my reviews of
severance i'll be doing every single
episode and make sure to follow me at
steve varley show on twitter instagram
and tick tock for more of me and if you
really love what i do here i appreciate
you become a member today that will help
me do this full time and make more
videos for you guys and get special
perks as well and i'll see you next time